la morsure du serpent à rachat de mes
bras et c'est bien amèrement que j'ai
imploré le ciel de me laisser une chance
de thé vite et le fiel avec mon
instrument tout au bout de mes doigts
alors des poèmes japonais nicolas en
invente chaque jour jaune il écrit
il crée et sur un type dessinée il
devient aisé aux portes et cette
créativité la peine il ya 15 ans nicolas
est diagnostiqué schizophrène paranoïde
moi je pense qu'à la base c'est vraiment
un besoin de s'extérioriser de
s'exprimer en fait et je crois
effectivement le ce aussi une sorte de
catharsis en fait c'est voies détournées
potentiellement c'est voilà trois un peu
c'est un peu une année spéciale chimie
en fait c'est comme transformer du plomb
en or quoi c'est la canaliser des
pulsions qui peuvent être pas mauvaises
entre guillemets mais qui peuvent être
assez violente et les traduire dans sous
une forme artistique nicolas oui alors
sortir tiens puisqu'on a un petit peu de
temps là la découverte de sa maladie est
un choc pour lui et pour sa famille mais
l'acceptation et rapide notamment chez
sa mère un soutien et sa première fan
moi quand je vois les fleurs suis assez
ému parce que parce que je retrouve déjà
la patte qu'il avait qu'il avait acquise
quand il était dans son école d'art et
en même temps je vois cette fluidité 7
cette aisance cette sorte de spontanéité
qu'en plus très très maîtrisée c'est la
plus belle aventure qui me soit arrivée
j'adore mes autres fils c'est pas la
question mais c'est vrai qu'avec lui
j'aurais j'ai un contact et là ça
continue un jet à contacter vraiment
privilégiés on rigole énormément il a
énormément d'humour
merci portable à la mi mai nicolas
débute un stage à les atrides 10 de
plaisir un stage conseillé par son
spécialiste une phase d'apprentissage
donc je suis très à l'écouté et c'est
vrai que en fait pourquoi j'ai pris
quand même une avant une année
sabbatique
enfin voilà parce que j'étais au chômage
enfin pour diverses raisons et donc du
coup c'est le rythme est un peu vrai le
rythme de travail d'écriture à reprendre
mais il faut se faire violence et puis
ça passe ça va je découvre complètement
mais c'est intéressant aussi mais c'est
vrai qu'on va peut-être potentiellement
plus d'aptitudes à apprendre des choses
quand on est jeunes n'ont pas le choix
j'ai 35 ans maintenant aujourd'hui son
stage s'est transformé en cdi
nicolas travaille aux réglages lumière
pour des compagnies artistiques et
continue de créer pour combattre les
clichés